the Joe Rogan experience I watched this
they had this video online it was live
videos of bald eagles having babies and
that you could watch him they had
cameras set up on him and everything it
was fascinating it and it ended terribly
though the they showed you how the mom
would sit and the dad would go out and
hunt and then he came back and he would
just his shift was like an hour or two
and she was the rest of the time but he
would go out and bring food back and the
poor thing
I think it was the mom going to get food
it got [ __ ] hit by a commercial
airline well I got hit by a jet on a
landing and killed the mom and so they
had to help the birds because the dads
don't go you know that would have been
the end of their ass so I think to help
around him I don't know what they do
they might there's savage [ __ ] Birds
savage bird Ravens too I learned about
Ravens being a raving fan I watched this
documentary one time just [ __ ] lady
in England had a rave and a pet raven
you know that british that little that
it's like an upside down you that car
that weird old car it's just that it's
just like a little like a like we rent
the things upside down yeah this she had
a pet raven that was they said I guess
they're the most intelligent bird and
this thing she would keep the keys in
ignition in the windows down and she'd
be like we're gonna go for a ride and
the Raven would fly in the car start the
car with its beak sit on the door she
get in she started driving and then he
would just fly right next to the car
wherever she went
why it was unbelievable I don't believe
I could not get over it so she had like
a relationship with this 100% and this
raven knew and loved it like he was like
huh let me go start the car for you yeah
it was that she would say let's go for a
drive as a raven knew what she was
saying
out out boom in the car grab that [ __ ]
with it's because they're big but
they're big too and just turn those
little keys and he would wait for her to
get in she'd start driving he lie right
next to it I don't know you might look
for it but I watched it they're so smart
I saw a video one using a tool to get
another tool so that it could get into
something like they did these tests to
find out how they intelligent they were
to see if they could do
problem-solving I'm gonna get food and
so it had to use like one small stick in
order to pull out a larger stick and the
larger stick to pull out this thing that
got him the food and it figured it out
and figured it out quick like quicker
than my kids would have it's crazy do it
it's like this little conniving [ __ ]
there's a great video one of my favorite
videos online of this one raven that
taunts these two cats into a fight it
stars of them up into a fight yeah
they're both what is this lady crazy
[ __ ] whoever you are if you stick your
penis in that lady you deserve
everything you got coming to you
everything what the [ __ ] you fix it in
that bag oh my god I don't know
look at that heads your heads baby heads
it's dude over here just don't like it's
nothing yeah that corner for the guy
next he's just checking this Twitter he
probably does even though he hasn't even
looked over nobody's sitting next to
that [ __ ] though like nom I'll stand
all the way over look at it I mean
everything about her looks weird she's
like when do I kill myself today not
today when she looks crazy [ __ ] with
metal over boots sure you're goth hold
it was it's a sure you're goth by but
are you dejectedly riding the subway
with your Raven God you can find the
Raven provokes hats it's one of my
favorite videos cuz this is two cats and
they're on opposite rooftops like right
next to each other and they're like wow
look at each other this raven comes over
[ __ ] with one of the calves like come
on me watches so the the cat's chillin
and then the raven flies over to where
the cat is and starts [ __ ] with them
and after he starts [ __ ] with them
then he flies over to where the other
cat is and he starts [ __ ] with him he
gets behind him he's like hey [ __ ] what
are you doing he gets just close enough
for the catholic [ __ ] like not
a normal fly back over here and I'll
[ __ ] with this coffee though so he just
but he's doing it on purpose this little
[ __ ] but you could tell
he's just getting the cat's riled up hey
[ __ ] look I'm a bird and I'm right
behind you
[ __ ] cats like no no no no I'm
gonna get this other cat and then look
at each other the cat's like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
no [ __ ] you look he's keeps getting
closer to the cat why would a raven get
close to a cat I mean why why would any
bird yeah the only reason why is because
he's [ __ ] with him he's doing he's
these cats are killing each other and
this rave is like you dumb hos oh look
they fall into that hole and that Raven
is just hanging out with them an animal
that can fly on the ground vulnerable
watching these two cats fight [ __ ] he
jumped into the hole that is a crazy-ass
bird that is a crazy [ __ ] bird but
also confident right he knows how quick
he can move see coming in from the sides
he's like no you're not done yet
that cat is still alive [ __ ]
what kind of a [ __ ] are you hell it's
such a weird weird animal like once they
found out that these things are smart
they're like look in comparative tests
when it comes to like problem solving
they're as smart or smarter than
chimpanzees Ravens yes yeah it's what I
hear they're super smart super smart
like they don't know how smart that we
did the limitation is that they've got
these feet and wings but if you gave
them like fingers and have them like
problem-solve stuff like like spell
their name and [ __ ] and you know you
give them some food they might be able
to do that because chimps can kind of do
stuff like that here's one look at this
raven
oh crow raven pretty pretty say what is
the difference is it rain and bigger
yeah a lot bigger yeah but they're all
smart so this little [ __ ] realizes
that if he puts these rocks in that
water that the water will float up and
he'll be able to get that food so you
can't quite reach that food so he keeps
dropping those rocks in there to try to
raise the level of the water up how the
[ __ ] does he figure that out man like
look at that that's
crazy oh you just get it just Oh
light versus heavy what is this one all
kinds of experiments with them oh wow
look at that it says it's a casual
understanding of water displacement up
by a crow there's the name of the video
study done by Auckland New Zealand the
University what just makes you think
right look we always define intelligence
by how much can it manipulate in its
environment and where that throws us off
is like dolphins and orcas and whales
because they're really smart and they
can't they can't do anything they have
flippers but we know they have these
really complex languages and calm and
they have they have Baltimore accents
dolphins and orcas have accents do that
yeah I don't know how they can't tell
what the [ __ ] they're saying but they
can tell where they're from really so
it's a regional thing not like
bottlenose versus a spotted has a
different accent yeah they're from
different spots of the world different
accents
[Applause]